Jake: 没关系没问题
Jake: It's okay, no problem.
Jake: 再再来了
Jake: Let's try again.
Jake: 硕
Jake: Shure.
Shure: 哎哎哎
Shure: Hey, hey, hey.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Katrina:  你那个甜品展架啥的买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy that dessert display stand?
Tasha: 买了
Tasha: Yeah, I bought it.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Jake: 啊这个可以
Jake: Ah, this is good.
Tasha: 哎他这个居然没有停止他的进度哎
Tasha: Hey, it's surprising that this didn't stop progressing.
Jake: OK可以
Jake: OK, this is good.
Jake: 呃我们先收拾收拾去吧
Jake: Uh, let's clean up first.
Shure: 一想到刚刚所有人都在外面然后在里面洗澡
Shure: Thinking about how everyone was outside and then taking a shower inside...
Shure: 然后在里面洗澡
Shure: ...taking a shower inside...
Shure: 好，好羞耻
Shure: ...so embarrassing.
Katrina:  害怕不
Katrina: Were you scared?
Katrina:  害怕我们进去吗
Katrina: Were you scared we might go in?
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 还好你没洗碗
Tasha: Good thing you didn't have to wash the dishes.
Alice: 不是我一般晚上洗
Alice: I usually wash them at night.
Jake: 那那你你先画我们先上去
Jake: Then you draw, and we'll go up first.
Katrina:  我马上就来
Katrina: I'll be there soon.
Jake: 走我们上去收拾收拾
Jake: Let's go, we'll go upstairs and clean up.
Katrina:  线条小狗
Katrina: The lines, puppy.
Tasha: 你要在楼上洗碗吗
Tasha: Are you going to wash the dishes upstairs?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 是在楼上洗碗吗
Tasha: Are we washing the dishes upstairs?
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  我们要洗碗
Shure: We have to wash the dishes.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Jake: 洗了吗
Jake: Have you washed them?
Shure: 没洗呢
Shure: No, not yet.
Tasha: 带这个厨房湿巾就行了
Tasha: Just take these kitchen wipes.
Alice: 上面有洗衣液吗
Alice: Is there any laundry detergent upstairs?
Alice: 不是
Alice: No.
Alice: 不是洗衣液
Alice: Not laundry detergent.
Alice: 洗洁精还有啥
Alice: Dish soap, what else?
Alice: 这个拿吗
Alice: Should I take this?
Alice:需要拿着个吗
Alice: Do I need to hold this?
Katrina: 我酒还剩一口
Katrina: I still have one sip of wine left.
Alice:2
Alice: 2
Alice:哎呀我的裙
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice: 这个味
Alice: This smell.
Tasha: 怎么这么厚的感觉
Tasha: Why does it feel so thick?
Lucia: 他就是很厚但是一直没找到地方放
Lucia: It's really thick, but we haven't found a place to put it.
Alice: 哎呀这个味先放一下啊
Alice: Oh no, this smell, let's put it aside for now.
Alice: 啊直接倒进去吗
Alice: Are we just pouring it in directly?
Tasha: 我靠你这手
Tasha: Wow, look at your hand.
Jake: 嗯我去我这手
Jake: Yeah, look at my hand.
Tasha: 嗯来
Tasha: Yeah, here.
Alice: 直接倒进去
Alice: Just pour it in.
Alice:不会把下水下水道给堵了吗
Alice: Won't it clog the drain?
Tasha: 他不是有网吗
Tasha: Isn't there a strainer?
Tasha: 我在当时想
Tasha: I was thinking...
Alice:就这个油一凝固他不就
Alice: Once the oil solidifies, won't it...
Tasha: 所以尽快让他溶下去吗
Tasha: So we should melt it quickly.
Tasha: 没关系我们后面不用这个池子
Tasha: It's okay, we're not using this sink later.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:乾坤
Alice: Universe.
Jake: 得得这样是吧
Jake: Like this, right?
Jake: 这样有用吗
Jake: Will this work?
Alice: 没关系随便吧
Alice: It's okay, whatever.
Tasha: 有用
Tasha: It works.
Alice: 好玩吗
Alice: Is it fun?
Jake:我也不想攉呀
Jake: I don't want to play either.
Jake: 说实话
Jake: Honestly.
Alice:哈哈哈
Tasha: 我们要打扫干净才能离开这个民宿
Tasha: We need to clean up before we leave this Airbnb.
Tasha: 对吗
Tasha: Right?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Yeah, right?
Jake: 我现在擦也没啥用
Jake: Cleaning now is pointless.
Alice: 要不用这个先洗洗这个吧
Alice: Should we wash this first?
Tasha: 这这这里面不是有
Tasha: Isn't there...
Tasha: 洗洁精吗
Tasha: Dish soap here?
Alice: 这个油比较多嘛
Alice: There's a lot of oil here.
Jake:先先先先洗这个是吧
Jake: Wash this first, right?
Jake: 先洗哪个呀
Jake: Which one should we wash first?
Alice:都行
Alice: Either one is fine.
Tasha: 那你就先洗锅吧
Tasha: Then you wash the pan first.
Jake: 好那这个我我扔
Jake: Okay, then I'll throw this away.
Jake: 我扔哪了
Jake: Where should I throw it?
Tasha: 哪个
Tasha: Which one?
Jake:里面的东西
Jake: The stuff inside.
Alice: 这个垃圾桶呢
Alice: The trash can is full.
Alice: 满了
Alice: It's full.
Jake: 来来袋子袋子上袋子
Jake: Get a bag, get a bag.
Alice:袋子
Alice: A bag.
Alice: 是不是在那啥
Alice: Is it over there?
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Alice:用这个吧
Alice: Use this.
Jake: 这有啥才艺
Jake: What kind of talent is this?
Tasha: 倒
Tasha: Pour it.
Tasha: 还好我觉得今天浪费的一点都不多
Tasha: Fortunately, I think we didn't waste much today.
Jake:都拍下来了
Jake: It's all recorded.
Jake: 哎呀不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry.
Tasha: 这不是不好意思就可以的
Tasha: "Sorry" isn't enough.
Jake: 对不起对不起对不起
Jake: I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:私密马赛
Alice: Excuse me.
Jake: 我先放地上吧
Jake: I'll just put it on the floor first.
Jake: 可以吗
Jake: Is that okay?
Tasha: 放呀
Tasha: Sure, put it.
Jake: 我也没有别的地方放
Jake: I don't have anywhere else to put it.
Jake: 或者放那边桌上
Jake: Or put it on that table.
Jake: 放我桌上
Jake: On my table.
Jake: 喔这个竟然
Jake: Oh, this actually...
Alice: 我这个衣服没兜
Alice: My clothes don't have pockets.
Alice: 难道我要别在我的腰上
Alice: Should I pin it to my waist?
Alice: 笑死了
Alice: So funny.